I want my skills protected just like my
banks are protected just like everything
else and I get a kick I was watching a
politician weak ineffective politician
last night I'll tell you in there but I
don't want to embarrass anybody and he
was talking about no guns no this no
that and yet he's surrounded by three
guys carrying guns I said well what are
they going to give up their guns they're
not going to give up their guns but he
wants everybody else to have no guns all
right so and you have plenty of them all
right that was from today's listening
session that was at the White House two
in a row two days in a row following
this horrific mass shooting last week
while the president has now shown
leadership he's trying to find solutions
keeping our schools and our kids safe
joining us now a big Warren warm CPAC
welcome to be counsel to the president
Kelley on camera
right so
there have been a lot of school shooting
you don't like a lot of issues like
everybody talked about opening a noir
and nobody did it till President Trump
did it in Jerusalem maybe nobody talked
to him everyone talked about in the
capital to Jerusalem nobody did it but
Donald Trump is he gonna now solve this
problem of school shootings I believe he
can and he will I think we should all be
very grateful that Donald J Trump is the
president at this time for it for the
president United States to hold
back-to-back sessions yesterday and
today today public safety school safety
with elected officials with
commissioners of the police with
sheriffs with educators and of course
the mayor of parkland Florida has really
been a remarkable woman throughout this
for him to do that yesterday yes and
today and yesterday to have the parents
and the students there and those who
have suffered over the years including
last week in Florida Sean this is a man
who's always listening he has listened
to the angel moms and dads he's listened
to the Obama care victims he's listened
to the coal miners he's listened to the
families and the business owners come to
the White House and say how they would
spend the tax savings that they would
get from any cut he's listened to big
business to small business to aspiring
entrepreneurs to young people all across
this country whose future is more
prosperous more safe because of him and
he's now taken this all the way into I
think a scourge on our society and there
are many but for the president United
States to welcome these people into his
house yesterday they were in the state
dining room and to just listen he didn't
make it about himself as politicians
often do he didn't interrupt them he
spoke very little very sparingly he and
the Vice President took into account all
of the I think the emotion in the brief
but also the resolve in the person
purposeful we just played a clip of the
president we he also spoke yesterday
about how the average school shooting is
over in three minutes
even the best first responders as great
as they are they need six minutes to get
there that's why and and he made another
good point
all these politicians all these
celebrities all these people that would
like to disarm
Americans that aren't willing to put
retired armed military retired armed
police in the schools they're usually
pretty well protected with their own
security forces of armed people like at
the Oscars etc so there's a lot of
hypocrisy here and the lectures that
come that come from people that
themselves have security and armed
guards is a little falls flat at least
on my years and I think most people hear
this president is pretty adept at I'm
pointing out hypocrisy and I think in
this case it's been said by many people
over the last week and it's indubitably
true that if we really care about our
children and we all do in this country
then we have to at least protect them
the way we protect many many plays
stadiums and obviously banks have been
talked about so clearly anywhere where
there is a celebrity I look at our
children much that way I think they're
our future heroes and there's
celebrities in their own right in their
own households and I think that they
deserve the same protection that many
people who can afford it you know I have
I have a I have a scenario that I think
everybody at home and everybody here I
want you to just think about for one
second if god forbid you ever find
yourself in any administration building
I don't know where or how this ever
would happen and there's an active
shooter would you or would you not want
retired armed military retired armed
police on site so you have a fighting
chance I think we owe that to America's
children as a simple fundamental basic
front line of defense hasn't it made
that point again and again today and for
the second consecutive day he had the
cameras rolling in the mics open the
entire time unscripted unrehearsed
unfiltered and I would say quite
unexpected and he made that point today
we need to harden our targets and our
schools need to be places where a
would-be mass murderer believes that he
or she is not going to have their way
there that if they know there are that
they can't easily get in and do their
damage that they will think twice about
that and he made that very clear he came
in really tough today about that because
he wants to make sure that we saw this
once and for all these are necessary
conversations and not easy solutions but
we should give I think the president and
the vice president others would be
credit for having that conversation what
do you make of the liberal media and
they're just within seconds and hours
they're out there with their predictable
talking points and attacking the
president what really missing the
essence of what yesterday really was
about if you listen very carefully to
the people in that room and they had the
floor they came there with ideas they
came there with certainly with what's
controversies I think that the
disagreement in the room yesterday over
policy from the affective families
reflects very much the disagreement
across this country but that
disagreement needs to be heard and the
different ideas need to be aired and
what I what I believe is that they you
still have I think there are many people
in the media who are trying to get the
story I think there's still too many who
are trying to get the president and it's
unfortunate that would happen after a
day like yesterday where even some of
his fiercest critics say it was a very
positive event it was a very good good
thing for him to have hosted at the
White House at the same time anybody who
came away yesterday and took one little
snippet and try to manipulate anybody's
words is really being disingenuous as to
the tone of the content of the entire
event and being quite disrespectful to
the people who were in the room who were
really the ones speaking Kellyanne
Conway let's give her a big warm CPAC
welcome the Kois great to have you thank
you
[Applause]